Traduttore: Gianna Carroni
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Quanti di voi hanno un cane,
o un gatto, a casa?
(Alza la mano)
Tanti.
Allora, sappiate che avete
un vantaggio evolutivo,
da questo punto di vista.
Quelli che vedete sono soltanto
alcuni ritagli di giornale,
ma veramente pochi,
che dicono come avere un animale a casa
ci renda persone più intelligenti,
vale anche per i bambini;
rinforza il sistema immunitario,
soffriamo meno di allergie,
abbiamo meno probabilità
di contrarre infarti, addirittura.
Ma perché succede questo?
Perché, nel momento
in cui tu accarezzi un cane,
si abbassa la pressione sanguigna,
liberi endorfine e via dicendo?
La motivazione principale
è che il bisogno
di relazionarci agli animali
è innestato nel nostro DNA,
ci siamo coevoluti con loro.
Non esiste un'umanità
senza le altre specie animali.
E questo vale per tutte le culture,
anche quelle più povere.
Questa è la fotografia
di una fase che si chiama "maternaggio",
che è stato quello che, per esempio,
ha reso possibile
la domesticazione del lupo,
che poi è diventato cane.
Noi pensiamo agli animali,
ci confrontiamo con loro
ogni volta che dobbiamo
creare, immaginare,
anche soltanto costruire
la nostra identitàdi esseri umani.
Spesso il concetto di animalità
era "tutto ciò che non è umano".
Oggi la si pensa un po' diversamente:
anche l'essere umano
ha una propria animalità.
Ecco, val la pena però
di considerare questo:
non è sufficiente
avere un cane in giardino,
per avere dei benefici,
o se non altro questi benefici
possono essere massimizzati, ma come?
Rendendoci conto che in ognuna
di queste piccole teste -
o grandi teste, se parliamo
ad esempio di elefanti -
esiste un mondo, una soggettività,
un particolare modo di percepire il mondo,
una vita emotiva.
E già Darwin, nell'Ottocento,
scriveva l'espressione delle emozioni
nell'animale e nell'uomo
comparandole tra di loro.
Ecco, quello che stiamo per vedere
è un filmato di un gorilla
che si chiama Koko.
È una femmina di gorilla
cui è stato insegnato
il linguaggio dei segni.
Quindi Koko può raccontare come si sente.
È interessante questo.
Qui Koko sarà alle prese con un film,
che è il suo film preferito.
C'è una parte molto particolare,
però, in questo film,
in cui c'è un commiato
tra un bambino e la propria mamma,
le persone a cui
questo bambino è affezionato.
E Koko vive talmente
intensamente questa cosa,
talmente tanto si dispiace,
che gira le spalle.
Si mette di schiena, non vuole guardare.
(Voci in sottofondo)
Ecco qui.
E guardate l'espressione!
Guardate l'espressione: non ce la fa,
è troppo forte questa cosa [per lei].
Il video continua.
"Ce l'hai il coraggio?"
Adesso comincia a gesticolare.
"Bene"
"Sorriso"
["Accigliato / triste"]
"Stanno piangendo,
perché è una situazione difficile"
"La dolcezza della mamma"
"Amore"
È una piccola incursione
nella mente di un animale.
E pensate a quando noi
prendiamo questi animali,
li rendiamo schiavi,
li mettiamo in uno zoo
e poi andiamo lì
mangiandoci le noccioline.
Che tipo di realtà loro devono vivere, no?
È interessante la frase
di Konrad Lorenz, che dice:
"Chiunque conosca intimamente
un mammifero superiore,
come un cane o una scimmia,
e non si convince che tale essere
ha sentimenti simili ai suoi,
è psichicamente anormale."
Ed è questo renderci conto
che ci rende essere umani migliori -
Gandhi già diceva:
"Il progresso morale di una nazione
lo si può misurare in base
a come tratta gli animali."
Il fatto è che se noi riconosciamo,
nell'animale, una mente pensante,
allora sorgono degli interrogativi.
Possiamo confrontarci, possiamo capire
che cosa sta succedendo lì dentro.
E poi, un'altra bella cosa
è che l'animale,
soprattutto i nostri cani a casa,
ti accettano un po' così come sei.
Sono maestri di accettazione
incondizionata.
Che tu sia alto, basso, ricco, povero,
a loro non frega nulla;
però sono molto distanti da noi.
Sono più distanti di altri esseri umani.
Ed ecco che questa relazione
diventa una palestra
per esercitare empatia, compassione,
comunicazione non verbale e via dicendo.
C'è stato uno psicologo,
un neuroscienziato per la precisione,
che ha studiato il modo
in cui i cani ci amano.
Li ha sottoposti ad una tomografia
ad emissione di positroni,
mentre il cane era in "resta",
gli aveva insegnato questa cosa.
C'è stato un consenso:
i cani potevano andarsene quando volevano,
e un consenso che i proprietari
hanno dovuto firmare,
perché dovevano essere trattati bene.
Ebbene lui ha scoperto
non soltanto che gli animali ci amano,
ma anche il modo particolare
in cui lo fanno.
E la cosa straordinaria
è che poi abbia scritto un articolo
apparso sul New York Times,
dal titolo: "Anche i cani sono persone".
Perché persone?
Perché noi lo utilizziamo
come sinonimo: umano uguale persona.
No, "persona" deriva
da "maschera", "carattere",
ciò che caratterizza un individuo.
E quanti di noi,
che hanno il proprio cane a casa,
anche due cani della stessa cucciolata,
ognuno ha la propria "personalità", diciamo.
È questo renderci conto
che magnifica questa relazione, no?
Ci sono state anche
delle sentenze giuridiche:
in India hanno decretato
che i delfini sono "persone non umane".
La Corte dei Giudici di Buenos Aires
ha decretato che un orangutan,
che viveva nello zoo di Buenos Aires,
fosse una persona non umana
e ne ha ordinato
l'immediata scarcerazione,
quindi poi se ne sono occupati
in un santuario in Brasile.
Quindi anche giuridicamente
c'è un seguito da questo punto di vista.
Ed è nato un movimento
che si chiama "Minding Animals".
"Mind" è non soltanto "mente",
ma anche "presta attenzione":
"mind the step", "occhio al gradino".
Ecco, "Minding Animals"
significa riconoscere
che gli animali abbiano una mente,
e trattarli con attenzione,
trattarli con cura.
C'è stato uno psicologo,
che si chiama Paul Ekman,
che ha studiato l'espressione
delle emozioni negli esseri umani,
e ha visto che, in tutto il mondo,
gioia, tristezza, paura,
sorpresa e disgusto
vengono espresse nello stesso modo.
Ebbene, hanno fatto
lo stesso studio nei cani:
ed è risultato
che anche loro, tutti quanti,
hanno delle espressioni comuni.
E le nostre capacità empatiche
vengono sviluppate
nel momento in cui ci esercitiamo
a guardare queste espressioni.
(Risate)
In modo che quando siamo
di fronte a un animale,
possiamo renderci conto,
come in questo caso,
che c'è disagio, una lieve paura,
oppure euforia.
(Risate)
O al contrario,
quando ci relazioniamo
con animali selvatici,
non sono soltanto belli da vedere,
ma possiamo riconoscere
protezione, cura, amore.
Esattamente come ci dicono
gli etologi cognitivi.
Questi sono macachi che fanno il bagno
in acque termali in Giappone.
Sono delle pozze termali libere,
soprattutto per loro,
sono diventate un'icona.
E riuscite a vederla, questa espressione
di completo relax e abbandono,
sul loro volto, giusto?
Come anche qui possiamo vedere
un'espressione di curiosità e attenzione:
questa è la faccia di un animale vivo,
che fa esattamente
la vita che dovrebbe fare.
È molto, molto, molto diverso
rispetto a quando ci sono
situazioni come questa.
Non brutte soltanto perché sono in gabbia.
È che noi, su questi volti,
possiamo riconoscere
disperazione, rassegnazione:
questa testa inclinata di lato,
e la bocca aperta, e gli occhi bassi,
è dire: "Ho urlato,
ho urlato tutto il tempo,
ma nessuno ha aperto
questa caspita di gabbia."
E attenzione:
la maggior parte degli animali
che sul nostro pianeta
interagiscono con gli esseri umani
vivono in questo modo.
Perché noi abbiamo una convinzione:
"È fatto tutto per noi".
Non rendendoci conto che, invece,
siamo in un ecosistema,
siamo interdipendenti.
Non siamo in un sistema isolato.
Non siamo al centro.
Siamo parte della rete della vita.
Questa è una foto terribile,
di un animale che viene schiavizzato,
cioè inseguito -
per molti animali succede questo.
Ed è parte di una campagna di PETA.
Quanto diverso, invece,
è guardare gli animali nel loro habitat,
o che fanno la vita che devono.
E sull'espressione del piccolo
voi potete guardare
che c'è curiosità, giocosità;
e nell'espressione della mamma,
un sacco di pazienza.
E uno dice, "Ma Angelo, possibile?
Anche negli occhi di un ippopotamo
posso vedere queste cose, siamo sicuri?
L'espressione non è sempre quella?"
Beh, vi dico che quando
un ippopotamo è arrabbiato,
ve ne accorgete subito,
senza ombra di dubbio!
Val la pena, quindi -
e per questo gli animali,
soprattutto quelli nelle nostre case,
ci lanciano la possibilità
di esercitarci nello sviluppare empatia.
Perché ad ogni nostra azione,
gesticolazione,
tono di voce, espressione del volto,
stringere le distanze, allontanarci,
guardare da una parte o dall'altra,
loro cambiano la loro espressione,
anche di poco.
Ed è essere attenti alle sottigliezze
che ci rende ancora più bravi
empaticamente.
Per esempio, queste sono
due foto del mio cane:
sembrano identiche,
ma ci sono delle differenze.
Nella foto di destra
avete delle orecchie
più larghe, per esempio,
avete una testa che si scosta di lato.
È una testa lievemente più bassa.
E questo ha un significato.
Ma la prima cosa che dobbiamo fare
è accorgerci di questa cosa.
Non tanto attribuirgli
subito un significato.
È vivendo con loro
che si imparano un po' le cose.
Ecco che così possiamo andare
ancora più a fondo,
e riconoscere tenerezza.
Gli animali sono genitori favolosi,
non distratti dagli smartphone.
Riuscite a vederle adesso queste cose, no?
Quindi non è un'impressione,
uno vede una foto come questa e dice:
"Ah, sembra quasi che sia amore."
No, no, è proprio così!
Sono capaci di questi
sentimenti, gli animali.
Così come possiamo vedere
l'intensità di questo sguardo,
tra un genitore e il piccolo.
Ho una bambina di nove anni,
e ho visto tanti genitori -
me compreso, a volte -
che non hanno la stessa
pazienza degli animali.
Sono genitori favolosi,
possiamo imparare tanto da loro.
Qui c'è un sacco di presenza.
Non sono distratto con altro.
E tra l'altro questa presenza
è personalizzata allo stato
in cui ti trovi in questo momento,
non soltanto a te come individuo.
Presenza.
Cioè essere lì.
Invece tuo figlio ti parla,
o fate qualcosa,
e tu stai pensando già ad altre cose.
È uno dei mali del nostro tempo,
è quello che alza lo stress così tanto.
O anche, vuoi occuparti di altro?
Ma sto attento a quello che fai:
supervisiono!
Oppure, questo è ancora più interessante.
Avete un cucciolo
che viene redarguito e ammonito:
"Questa cosa non devi farla."
Lo vedete, il cucciolo è contrariato.
Dice: "Argh!"
Però guardate l'espressione dell'adulto.
Gli sta dicendo: "Non è in dubbio
l'amore che io provo per te.
Non sei in dubbio tu in quanto individuo.
È in dubbio soltanto
il tuo comportamento."
E quante volte noi ce ne dimentichiamo:
"Se non fai come ti dico,
ti privo del mio amore."
Ecco che gli animali diventano maestri
anche di amore incondizionato.
Non dipende da quello che fai,
quanto bene io ti voglio.
Posso darti una guida,
posso educarti da questo punto di vista.
Ma non è in dubbio
quello che io provo per te.
Questo crea esseri umani sani,
oltre che animali sani.
Ora, quello che secondo me
noi dovremmo notare, a questo punto,
è questo.
La mente degli animali,
quella che procura tutte queste emozioni,
cognizioni, aspettative, piani, curiosità,
creatività addirittura, per molti animali,
è un insieme di piccoli punti,
che noi chiamiamo neuroni,
che interconnettendosi tra di loro
diventano un cervello,
diventano una mente.
Ma la stessa cosa funziona
anche tra individui.
O meglio, tra organi del corpo,
per esempio: poi hai un individuo.
Ma tra individui succede una cosa:
diventa un'entità diversa.
Le proprietà di una cellula sono diverse
da quelle di un tessuto, di un cervello;
e le proprietà di una società,
o di un gruppo sociale,
sono diverse da quelle
del singolo individuo.
Ma c'è ancora di più da fare,
da questo punto di vista.
Diversi etologi cognitivi,
e diversi etologi anche,
oggi dicono che alla base dell'evoluzione
è possibile che non ci sia stata
la competizione, ma la cooperazione.
Anche tra specie differenti.
Questo è ciò che dovremmo ricordarci:
non più metterci
al di sopra degli altri animali,
pensando di essere
l'essere umano più intelligente.
Oggi si parla di intelligenze,
anche all'interno
degli essere umani stessi,
della sola specie umana.
Voglio dire, Einstein diceva:
"Ognuno è un genio.
Ma se giudichi un pesce
dalla sua capacità di salire sugli alberi,
quello penserà di essere stupido
per tutta la vita."
Non possiamo prendere
la nostra scala umana,
attribuirla agli altri animali
e dire: "Beh, questi qua sono stupidi."
Perché io ce lo vedo un uccello migratore
che guarda dall'alto in basso
un essere umano che si è perso
in campagna o in montagna,
e dice: "Guarda 'sto pirla,
io attraverso i continenti
orientandomi con i campi elettromagnetici,
e questo non riesce ad orientarsi
in un fazzoletto di terra grosso così."
Sono intelligenze diverse.
Una volta una mia amica
ha intervistato Margherita Hack.
Le ha detto: "Dottoressa, che mi dice
dell'intelligenza degli animali?"
E lei fa:
"Ognuno ha l'intelligenza che gli serve."
E allora, se questo è il punto,
cioè cooperare,
anche tra specie differenti,
per creare un ambiente
ancora più rispettoso dei nostri bisogni,
che ci faccia ritrovare
il senso della nostra esistenza,
val la pena appunto di considerare
la cooperazione interspecie.
E gli animali ce lo insegnano,
quindi io mi sono detto: "Perché no?"
Perché ho visto tante cose
da questo punto di vista.
Perché no?
Questa è un'alleanza tra leoni.
Grazie.
(Applausi)